quasiment tous quand l'un des rares
voyageurs puis à nantes il n'y a qu'un
bon et grand voyageur qui n'ont pas de
masque j'allais dire être leur écharpe
sur le nez mais il ya quand même des
voyageurs qui n'ont pas des masses qui
sortent de ces transilien alors que jean
pierre farandou la sncf me disais que
plus de 95% des gens qui se sont
présentés ce matin dans les transports
en commun parisiens porter des masques
donc ce message sanitaire est bien passé
on va vous montrer tient une petite
vidéo qui a été tournée des quelques
minutes par guillaume points
autre journaliste du figaro il était à
la gare de lyon la gare de lyon
guillaume a pu tourner tout à l'heure
que la distanciation dans les rames de
rer elle s'annonce très très très
compliqué je vous laisse découvrir ces
images images tournées à 6h28 deux
minutes avant l'heure de pointe t à 6h
du matin effectivement tient mal et pas
mal de route notamment en ile-de-france
qui ont été partiellement inondées en ce
week-end avec les intempéries y ait eu
un aussi l'autoroute 1 2 concernés c'est
pas très chargé sa mazars nous dit
edouard genre commence quand même alors
évidemment on n'est plus là il est 8h30
on est plus sur un trafic qui
ressemblerait
[Musique]
récession finie
les jeunes que marielle pour notre santé
à tous les parisiens
m
[Musique]